hey guys i'm ryan right so today i'm
doing a little something different
Jerry's birthday is just in a couple of
hours so I wanted to give him a little
gift what better than a little rap song
I'm introducing it like it's gonna be a
joke song but it's actually having from
the bottom of my heart I just can't seem
to express sincerity unless I am doing
the song so let's go into this let the
see a whole new side of Ryan ride we
grew up in school where the kids were
cruel fat bowl let's say by being artful
became best friends in third grade
pokemon cost two boys to relate my home
was a mess of emotions disaster risk but
I was never left for unless cuz he gave
me room to express people look at me now
and say how great I am the little did
they know how ashamed I am before I once
was as most of my life depression turns
to anger with risk being cut by my knife
I took it out on people anything to
belittle all those matter mostly boast
but once they saw the darkness the
friendship with the toast lost so many
friends over the years over the mistakes
that I made at the face so many beers
have to shed so many tears I could say I
was abandoned but I was the
[ __ ] victim and the one I took
my traumas out on the most was my best
friend who was living a life long roast
exaggerated movies of kids being bullied
but he was the real deal he was fed
despicable meals no reason to be
pointing and laughing but even I the one
calling in my best friend joining on the
hoechlin I could justify saying I wasn't
the only one ribbon away of someone sold
just for fun yeah let me blend in the
crowd don't mess with what makes you
proud I should have stood up hell my
chin up but I succumb to the bullying
behavior and now it causes me so much
anger cuz god damn i can't tell you how
much this man is my savior and friends
now for over 20 years and in those early
years I can still hear two little boys
through this day pursuing the same
careers more than
ups and downs to hell I was bound if
anyone should have left it should have
been him but if I ever needed him he'd
be there in an instant I've met so many
[ __ ] who talk about their background
so now they drop annoying spiteful
pounds Jerry could have ended up very
angry but it's funny how hilarity and
sympathy were born from abuse of
memories nurtured by loving family man
you should see this guy comedy he gets
as part of the cliché huh comedians
turning the pain in something Quantico
man I can't believe how [ __ ] up I was
controlling abusing for a man who was
constantly given always had his schedule
packed the list of helping others was
always stacked you want to know true
selfless behavior asked his real lover
who's obsessed with horror I meet people
who pride themselves on being
non-judgmental stick around him long
enough you see there being quite
hypocritical but Jay he was always real
it takes the time to understand how you
feel he never sacrificed himself to fit
in with others stay true to just being
himself so don't [ __ ] with his facial
features I could only imagine how bad
have been influenced I could have been
been insistent on since but he's the
only guy I know that I can call an angel
cried to him recently said I'm sorry for
being the devil he brushed it off said
it was years ago never held a grudge so
now we have this YouTube show if you
love me they love him too cuz I wouldn't
be me if wasn't for my reasons to Jerry
you taught me compassion he told me to
be understanding he taught me optimism
and not to play the [ __ ] victim so to
my brother I don't mean that
metaphorically cuz you're my blood
brother for you I put down my armor and
say I love you sure call it a bromance
smarty pants road for this love all
forever take a stance you've been there
for me since the beginning I mean that
literally will be there together to be
ending and the lives we will go down in
history so have a happy birthday my
friend and just know this friendships
never gonna end
the one day on there's that confidence a
breakthrough a persistence of
consistency will create an artistic
legacy being called one of the greatest
in history
anyway happy birthday Jerry